ah
estas son las noticias de france 24 el
gobierno de francia anticipar a la
presentación del proyecto de ley anti
cobit que pretende establecer la
obligatoriedad de la vacunación para
poder obtener el pase sanitario
indispensable para múltiples actividades
y acceso a diferentes lugares por su
parte el reino unido- indicó que no
impondrá restricciones adicionales
rusia indicó que no hará exigencias ante
la escalada de tensión con oxygen tb con
occidente pero advirtió que sí
responderá de manera técnico militar a
cualquier amenaza a su soberanía y
seguridad esto haciendo referencia a los
deseos de ucrania de incorporarse a la
otan que han provocado choques entre
moscú y kiev
y avanza en una corte de la ciudad de
nueva york las deliberaciones del jurado
sobre el caso de ghislain maxwell
acusada de reclutar adolescentes para
que fueran abusadas sexualmente por el
magnate jeffrey epstein de ser
encontrada culpable maxwell se enfrenta
a una condena de cadena perpetua
muy buenas tardes bienvenidos a las
noticias de france 24 soy santiago lópez
gonzález vamos a comenzar esta misión en
francia este país europeo planea imponer
nuevas medidas para controlar la rápida
propagación de la variante omicron de
kobe 19 en su territorio el gobierno del
presidente manuel marco anunció que
anticipará la presentación de un
proyecto de ley anti cobit la iniciativa
pretende imponer la obligación de
vacunarse como único requisito para
obtener el pase sanitario es decir que
elimina la otra opción que había
disponible de obtener el pase después de
presentar un test negativo presentado en
un periodo de 24 horas por su parte la
unión europea indicó que los ciudadanos
podrán seguir viajando dentro de las
fronteras de la unión haciendo uso de
los respectivos pases sanitarios pero
instó a los gobiernos a mitigar el
impacto de este repunte de contagio
la excursión un consejo extraordinario
de ministros se reunirá el lunes 27 de
diciembre donde se presentará un
proyecto de ley que le permitirá al
parlamento examinar el texto a inicios
de la próxima semana entre navidad y el
nuevo año aspiramos a una implementación
final del pase sanitario en la primera
mitad de enero no tenemos un segundo que
perder con la variante com y chrome para
segunda pero su mayor unión y también el
primer ministro del reino unido boris
johnson en una alocución a nivel
nacional afirmó que no hay evidencias
que indiquen que sea necesario imponer
más restricciones en el país escuchemos
with the thing
hoy no creemos que haya suficiente
evidencia que justifique tomar medidas
más duras antes de navidad'
continuaremos monitoreando a un micrón
muy de cerca y si la situación se
deteriora estaremos listos para actuar
si es necesario lo que significa que las
personas pueden seguir adelante con sus
planes de navidad we de christie's plans
en una reunión ante el pleno del
ministerio de defensa ruso el presidente
vladimir putin indicó que su país no
exigirá condiciones exclusivas en
materia de seguridad pero advirtió que
rusia responderá con firmeza ante
cualquier paso hostil por parte de
occidente el mandatario ruso recalcó que
en caso de que occidente mantenga una
línea agresiva moscú responderá con
medidas técnicos militares por su parte
eeuu indicó que cree que las
negociaciones con rusia para tratar los
temas de seguridad y la atención que hay
en torno al tema de ucrania tendrán
lugar a partir del próximo mes de enero
sobre este tema se refirió el mandatario
ruso escuchemos
recibes tu puesto
bishop para ser una opción libre he's
compras trans por supuesto como los
señalados y nuestros colegas de
occidente continúan con su forma
agresiva de actuar en respuesta
tomaremos las medidas militares y
técnicas adecuadas reaccionaremos con
dureza ante las medidas hostiles y
quiero enfatizar que tenemos todo el
derecho de hacerlo tenemos todo el
derecho de tomar medidas para garantizar
la seguridad y soberanía de rusia
dirigió tres y cambiamos de tema al
menos ocho personas fallecidas dejan
hasta el momento las inundaciones
provocadas por las fuertes lluvias en el
estado de selangor en el sur de malasia
otras decenas de miles de personas han
sido desplazadas ante la destrucción de
sus hogares de acuerdo con las
autoridades malayas todavía guardan la
esperanza de encontrar algunos
sobrevivientes atrapados en sus
viviendas o en algunas edificaciones
este tipo de fuertes lluvias son comunes
en malasia entre los meses de octubre y
marzo pero las inusuales precipitaciones
altas han provocado que varias regiones
sean anegadas ante el aumento del nivel
de los caudales de los ríos y de los
lagos
ejerciendo así presión sobre los
servicios de emergencia en ese país
asiático
y seguimos en asia porque filipinas
cinco días después del paso del tifón
rey por el sureste del archipiélago que
dejó más de 375 muertos el país se
mantiene en emergencia varias zonas
permanecen todavía en comunicadas y se
mantienen los cortes de los servicios de
agua y de electricidad el gobierno en
manila desplegó al ejército nacional
para agilizar las labores de búsqueda de
las personas que están reportadas como
desaparecidas y también para atender a
los afectados mientras que varias
organizaciones humanitarias han
solicitado ayuda a nivel internacional
para atender a las miles de personas que
quedaron sin hogar
nos vamos ahora hasta el norte del
continente americano en la ciudad de
nueva york avanzan las deliberaciones
del jurado del caso de isla y maxwell
acusada de reclutar y de preparar al
menos a cuatro adolescentes para que el
magnate jeffrey epstein abusara de ellas
si la justicia la encuentra culpable
podría enfrentar una condena a cadena
perpetua
expectativa y tensión en aumento así se
vive la recta final del caso de william
maxwell acusada de ayudar al magnate
jeff epstein a abusar de cuatro menores
de edad con la última audiencia cerrada
a su destino queda ahora en manos del
jurado que determinará si es culpable o
inocente
el juicio comenzó el 29 de noviembre un
día que las víctimas del multimillonario
catalogaron como esperanzador yeguas hoy
fue un día simbólicamente importante
para todas las sobrevivientes del mundo
entero en particular las sobrevivientes
de jeffrey epstein que como yo fueron
privadas de un día en la corte pero
tengo fe en el sistema de justicia y sé
que el jurado llegar a una conclusión
correcta
la acusación de la fiscalía está basada
en el testimonio de cuatro mujeres de
las que tres testificaron con seudónimos
y una más any farmer lo hizo
públicamente
maxwell por su parte ha negado todas las
denuncias nunca testificó en las
audiencias y lleva de 2020 en una cárcel
de brooklyn
me da un tremendo alivio estar cerca de
ella poder verla en carne y hueso o
incluso poder hablar con ella
es la primera vez que he hablado con
ella personalmente en 500 días desde que
comenzó su prisión preventiva
seis cargos están en juego entre ellos
conspiración tráfico sexual de menores y
tentar a un menor a viajar para
participar en actos sexuales ilegales
los fiscales han recordado sus vínculos
con epstein con el que dicen se
involucró sentimentalmente y dirigió
varios de sus negocios el magnate se
suicidó en una cárcel en manhattan en
2019 tenía 66 años y esperaba un juicio
por abuso sexual
y mientras gran parte del sector de la
ciencia está enfocando todos sus
esfuerzos en el desarrollo de una vacuna
contra el cob y 19 y sus variantes otros
trabajan en un abanico de nuevas
tecnologías pensadas para mejorar la
vida cotidiana durante la pandemia a
continuación les mostramos algunas de
ellas veamos
buscan devolverle al mundo la normalidad
científicos e ingenieros de distintos
países desarrollan nuevas tecnologías
para combatir el virus o simplemente
para facilitar la vida cotidiana en
medio de la pandemia desde mascarillas
mejoradas pasando por microchips
subcutáneos química de alta tecnología
píldoras y hasta robots de asistencia
en suecia una empresa especializada en
microchips ya promueve el uso de un
diminuto dispositivo que contiene la
información del pase sanitario para ser
escaneado cuando sea necesario aeronaves
no tienen batería no pueden transmitir
una señal por sí mismos así que son
básicamente pasivos están siempre
dormidos nunca pueden decir tu ubicación
sólo se activan cuando los tocas en un
smartphone los vehículos aéreos no
tripulados para entregar vacunas contra
el kobe facilitan la logística mientras
permiten un control óptimo de la
temperatura de almacenamiento cuidando
así miles de dosis que se distribuyen
durante este año en eeuu gana y ruanda
los robots se han tomado las calles de
singapur y finlandia para regular el
comportamiento de las personas y
reportar actividades que pongan en
riesgo la salud pública
la logística los juegos olímpicos de
beijing también estará asistida por
inteligencia artificial con vehículos no
tripulados encargados de entregar
suministros y minimizar la interacción
social utilizamos este carro para
trasladar los materiales dentro y fuera
de la burbuja y el personal puede [__]
los materiales sin salir de su zona en
el sector de la salud en india y canadá
ya empezaron pruebas de un aerosol nasal
a base de plantas y óxido nítrico que
busca reducir los síntomas en primeras
fases del contagio todas las propuestas
que aunque no acaban con el virus hacen
la vida en medio de la pandemia más
fácil y llevadera esto por el momento
aquí en las noticias de france 24 más
información en la página web en las
redes sociales y también en nuestra app
siga con nuestra programación buenas
tardes
[Música]